[Music]
okay so I have the great honor today of
being joined by Patrick Fabian aka
Howard Hamlin from better call Saul how
are you doing today Patrick I'm good how
you doing man I'm doing excellent
so Patrick a question I hope you've
always wondered about you is did you
have to audition for the role of Howard
Hamlin it's so funny um I get that a lot
and my I'm always sort of gobsmacked by
that I thought listen for every role
I've gotten basically that's all I know
and in this particular case you know I
didn't know Vince Gilligan and I didn't
know Peter Gould I didn't know any the
brain trust for Breaking Bad I've never
been on it and so when I auditioned I
actually auditioned for the casting
directors who did Breaking Bad share of
the aliens and Cherie Thomas and when I
went in for a better call Saul honestly
you know I'm a very practical minded
when it comes to the business and you
know he can have anybody they wanted for
this role and I assumed they had a list
already and I assumed you know they'd go
for you know movie stars somebody famous
you know in some level you know somebody
it was more well-known that was just my
thinking so I really didn't get a shot I
really was going in because I thought
that the ladies who cast this also cast
the walking dead and I hadn't bet on
that and I thought well maybe I can you
know do that I can get eaten by a zombie
that was kind of like my goal because
you know honestly I've been very
fortunate to be a working actor for
about 25 years and casting directors are
your bread and butter
they are gatekeepers to the
opportunities to get a job and I think
it's sort of rare air where people can
sort of you know pick and choose we see
that a lot but that's not the norm at
least the way I experienced it was most
of my friends experience it it's old
fashioned a caching director brings you
in you go up you've shown the show up in
the right clothes with the light right
lines memorized and you hope that you're
the answer so dude the question the
producers and directors have you know
yes or knowing that that this at the
time was a big project that is in that
Breaking Bad universe did it add this
extra pressure in the audition like were
you really nerve
going in or DG kind of keep your cool I
had honestly thought I had no shot
whatsoever so I was completely I was I
was untethered it's an expectation which
probably worked in my favor you know
what I mean I when I want to think about
it and also I said this before and I
almost hate repeating it but I hadn't
seen Breaking Bad I was one of those
dudes even though you know and part of
it was because I know my wife under the
bus here is because she was typing with
our first child when the pilot came out
then we were watching had she's rubbing
the miracle of life in her belly and
we're watching this pilot she turns to
me and she goes yeah I'm not on board
with this you know we ended up not
watching that we got involved with
having a kid we had a second kid and so
at some point you start missing it and
they have just missed it and even though
I was getting all these awards and I
felt a billboard I still didn't really
know what was it about man Wow
so literally I go into the audition for
this and and I'm just like I still don't
have I mean thank God I hadn't because
the pressure my brain what if they
change then so this is all sort of
outside the realm of my of my own
experience which I think was I don't
know fate fortune lucky stars aligning I
don't know but I honestly I was going to
get a job on the walking dead I thought
a shot so knowing this did you
after getting the great news that you
got the role of Howard Hamlin did you go
back and binge watch Breaking Bad did
that ever happen oh yeah now my wife and
I we have a point or at that point right
and and so we start watching Breaking
Bad of course like everybody else it's
like the tender chefs our drugs we're
like oh my gosh now we're staying up at
7:00 in the morning and now we're like
oh let's just watch one more it's 3:00
in the morning and my wife say like what
are we doing
our children are waking up at 5:30
they're not watching Breaking Bad so
there is this like there's this week
where we were just completely addled and
sleep-deprived because then I watched it
all I was like oh my gosh
yeah you know and by the way the you
know Breaking Bad is one of the first
ones that got to be binge that really
helped save it people started binging it
Netflix became Netflix you know and
thing to be able to watch this year
literally in one fell swoop it was my
first binge why and what what a bits to
have and I rolled right into eating all
of Breaking Bad and then basically two
weeks later going to the table read a
better call Saul and meeting Jonathan
banks for the first time you know so it
was really a glorious glorious sort of a
wrap-up yeah so a lot of things just
falling into place that is really cool
so yeah now I noticed in season one
right off the get-go like there is so
much lawyer talk going on how did you
prepare to play a lawyer like did you
have to read a bunch of law books or was
that intimidating at first
no the reason is this I played a lawyer
a whole bunch of times oh you can I get
legal legal drugs and stuff like that
you sort of research it as it goes so
your perception of it boy that's a lot
of law stuff specifically if you go back
and look what I'm actually talking about
and or referring to or what comes out of
my mouth it's actually very slight and
also because of the position I have on
the H and H hm so I'm not really doing
the grunt work I don't personally have
to know Wow right I have other people to
know I've got Chuck as my right-hand man
this way I'm working overtime you know
what I mean so really look back on it I
sit back and watch other people do the
work that being said the law a law on
the show is top-notch and airtight and
that's because we've got writers who are
so good and some of the writers actually
have siblings who are lawyers so they
run that through a sip it running up the
flagpole to make sure what we're putting
out there isn't isn't false that it's
actually the way the law would work
which we get a lot of great comments on
social media some people who are lawyers
are like yeah that's what lawyer is it's
files getting it late at night it's not
big you're out of order like oh no court
stuff really for a lawyer so yeah yeah
it's more definitely realistic for sure
I think that's what's so great about
vince gilligan and Peter gold too is
there always a realism to everything
they do yeah and I feel like now for a
character like Howard Hamlin can you
find any of yourself in him or is this a
pure thing that you get detached to do
yeah you know as a root
who you are these that's my own personal
belief on that I'm not really I wouldn't
say like I'm a character actor per se
you know unless it's just in that
respect so consequently what is common
with me and how it I think we both like
to have things in order I think both of
us have a sock drawer that is organized
I think we both have an idea of how
things should be done like a recipe and
I know there's only for my own
frustration of being the the only male
in a household with my wife daughters
with a button law it realized that the
way that I think it ought to go is it
always the way it's gonna go
so the frustrations and how it has that
he's out of control of in HHMI so the
experience of a life that's crazy
now when you're acting as Howard Hamlin
you know a lot of people say acting a
lot of it is reacting so mm-hm
I noticed the brilliant part of your
acting in this character is how much you
have to actually react to and how well
you do it and whether it's you know
Chuck being crazy or Jimmy's antics do
you find that a challenging part of it
like how much is being thrown your way
and is there a lot of improv going on
there's not a lot of improv going on our
writers craft
airtight scripts as far as we're
concerned and we respect that and so
therefore we try to we always try and
make whatever was given to us on the
page work that being said the looseness
that it may seem is a tribute to I think
both Bob and Michael McKean in
particular who really have a high-wire
sense of work that is interesting and
riveting to watch and it's riveting for
me as an actor as well and you're right
that the very first couple of episodes
of the whole series who doesn't wanna be
Bob who doesn't to be solved who doesn't
meet Jimmy he get these funny monologues
and he gets to be all over the place and
everybody wants to be like that and it's
an actually if the roots like years to
match that right because there is no
matching that certainly with the amount
of words and reactions that Howard would
have to the situation's so what we end
up doing is really listening to what's
going on and a acting is listening and
all those basics that came from acting
101 come into play especially when
working with really great writing and
really great actors because your job is
to just sort of absorb as the character
what is being dealt to you sort of you
know matriculated think about it
and let that filter into you and then
react accordingly the good news is we
also have a great directors who have
been you know handling us and you know
it feels like your quote unquote doing
something when you're talking but you're
doing just as much and I think honestly
I think Rhea seehorn is the is the queen
of that on the show her her in her life
let's just call it that is is revealing
and yet still she manages to put a
distance to it so it's that constant
thing like you think you're being let in
and then you're like am i yes brilliant
yeah she's brilliant in what she does
and she uh with her relationship with
Jimmy and Bob you know he's been given
such a heavy responsibility and I think
in the hands of anybody less capable
that whole storyline of that whole ocean
epillow
might be a little bit weaker I can't say
enough about how much I love watching
her work of working alongside of her
yeah and I completely agree with that
and especially the scene in Episode two
the season where Kim just lays into you
and Howard Hamlin and I was just blown
away by her energy and how much effort
she put into that and I was blown away
by how you are reacting because I feel
like there's also a part where it's like
you're giving that assist in a sense
like in basketball or you're also
nailing every little beat that people
subconsciously are noticing and it's so
important to get that best out of Kim
too so I think you guys have this like
incredible when the two of you are
together has always just been this like
I don't know I feel like I'm seeing two
aces and do you feel that like clique
you had right away with her on set I
consider a sister that I haven't that I
just finally met and we're comrades and
arms were also heard me and Michael
bando hurts for lack of a better term
are the junior members of the team you
know and it means Jonathan banks Gus
fring and Bob they are part of the world
already yes and they're veterans on that
and they're just you know their
hierarchy and they have work under their
belt so you know way Michael and I are
very much you know the junior members
and and so we bonded on that without a
doubt you know we were able to sort of
you know make fun
about that sort of thing and and you
know and that quickly I discovered
working with Ray made me better there
was no doubt about it you know I'm in a
scene with Ray and I was like oh good
she's going to react to whatever I give
her and then she makes me want to play
as well the fact that she's willing to
do that is really great and it helps the
writers in it it helps the directors and
it becomes fun so even though sometimes
the scenes were heavy and or darkened or
whatever there was always a sense of
play which i think comes through in
Episode two like you're talking about
you know I haven't actually seen it
right and so I'm curious because on the
day we we did it a number of ways to
sort of experiment to see where that
scene totally actually lay so Michelle
Maclaren directed that I'll be curious
to see what she decided which takes she
decided to use interesting speaking of
having not seen it are you a guy and all
of this you have a huge resume of stuff
you've done and in particular better
call Saul do you go and watch like every
episode you watch your work on screen
right after you one of those actors is
like I don't want to see myself I'm not
the director right if I start getting
into that idea I don't know how I'm
going to be now there is something to be
said for being able to see your
performance and to be able to make sure
that you're somehow on the same plane of
reality with the director and the writer
so we're all talking a common language
that I think is beneficial if I'm way
off base or or am i hearing direction or
suggestions that I find at odds with
what my I'm experiencing right
absolutely I'll be let me take a look at
it yes but almost never do I run around
to the monitor because all I'm gonna do
look I'm an actor all I'm gonna do is
most likely look around girl a oh I look
old who are those bags under my eyes I
mean there's a vein I mean there's a
matter you quality that I'll speak just
for myself I you know that I think gets
in the way of of seeing the work and in
the end also you know the scene is never
about just me the scene is never about
Howard Hamlin or whatever character I'm
playing when you see the final product
like I saw the premiere weeks ago at
comic-con it's a reminder of like it's
such a collaborative art and that's from
every department that there's there the
art department the writing deployment
delighted the gaffer
the grips the crew the director and all
that the sound right and then you see
the whole thing unfold internalized oh
I'm I'm a I'm a small part of this not
the focus of it but I'm really part of
the picture I am not be picture and I
think the act of like doing a scene and
running around and looking at yourself
for me would pay diminishing returns in
the end I trust the writers I trust the
directors they've hired and I trust my
scene partners and if there's any time
why I'm having questions I feel
comfortable for this situation in most
any good professional situation where
you can go ahead there's a way there's
an avenue to address that yeah but
looking at myself let's face it I look
at myself enough online already so I
know it's awesome sounds like you're a
team player and you can definitely tell
the whole cast is like that and I also
was gonna ask you to Howard Hamlin to me
is one of the most mysterious characters
on the show in the sense of we don't
really see his home life what he really
does outside of his job now knowing this
do you playing the character have to
create in your head a backstory for him
or do the directors or creators like
kind of give you little cues of where to
get so maybe where'd this guy come from
you know what I mean
yeah yeah well in this show first answer
to your third question writers know they
don't sit around and discuss backstory
with me because I think they're also
cooking up their own ideas and you'll
know what they think when you win the
script gets delivered I have not had
those conversations I'm sure that bob
has being the titular character when I'm
sure he's had discusses with them as
well because father also a writer and a
director and he wears many hats on his
Oh and I'm sure there's some discussion
but he's also been really clear about
he's an actor on the show so he's not
he's not there to keep the writing and
or like the show he's here to see what
they deliver and then discuss it for me
I make up stuff but I don't try to pin
it down okay I know some that just would
go and make a complete like and this is
where he's from and this is what he's
done I have a more nebulous okay sort of
idea I I know what my wife kind of looks
like but I'm not married to it pardon
the pun in case she doesn't look like
that
I used to grow that you know my dad Sean
Connery and he's gonna come back and
season five right you know I like to do
with the current circumstances my
assumption is since we haven't seen
anything bad and huh there is nothing
bad at home my assumption is when he
leaves the office he has a place to go
where he can he could let down his hair
as much as he can
small things like I think Howard likes
to swim right I think he probably likes
to swim in a speedo but he's never like
sort of things yeah no I think he
probably is not a great golfer but he's
a good companion on the golf course
those sort of things is what I dive into
see I see literally on your Instagram
you're into like the deep-sea diving
surfing do you ever throw that into
Hamlin's backstory in your head I think
it's a little too sweaty and open I
think Hammond likes a more controlled
situation okay
have the creators by any chance ever or
even like a writer tell you like where
they think Hamlin might end up at the
end of all this or is it just like hey
this is a script for the season just go
page by page I don't ask any questions
okay I don't necessarily want to know
the answer I don't think they know the
answers to
Vincent Peter have discussed this in the
writers room before man I mean obviously
there's an overarching idea of we know
where Jimmy ends up right we never saw
begins Breaking Bad so there's sort of a
line there right but everything else is
sort of up for grabs and you know the
internet loves to say like you know Kim
is dead I bet nachos that you don't make
to do that of course because you know
what life also sometimes it can be just
as sad with people just part ways right
it doesn't have to be a dramatic breakup
it's just all of a sudden people drift
in and out of people's lives and I think
there is something else a bit we go to
Turkey maybe err in the show so I don't
know what think Howard Hamlin has at the
end I'm past joking my pitch the idea
that Kim and him reconcile and go to the
Caribbean and pro bono work from a boat
and we get you know the second spin-off
that'd be great you know this season
you've had some real standout scenes
already acting-wise but in particular
for me I think your most emotional scene
was actually in the premiere when you
open up to Kim and Jimmy about pushing
Chuck out of HHM and your theory that
Chuck killed himself and I really felt
like this humanized Hamelin a lot for me
that's such an emotional scene you did
and it's on demand in that moment how do
you even get to that state because you
portrayed it so well but like how do you
get to that feeling well I the
compliment that's a thinking spiro is
the director she's a really great
actress director and I what I mean by
that is that she really knows how to set
literally the tone in the room as you're
working she knows how to make things
quiet or high or loud or whatever she
also knows how to talk to an actor at
least to this actor can drive right into
a psychic sort of thing with me it was I
like I'm not being hocus-pocus II I mean
the work that we do is sort of magic and
alchemy right we we try to get something
that magic dust that also requires that
the scene partners are great and Bob and
way even though it's sort of a flip in
that scene in particular I'm doing the
talking they're doing the listening yeah
they're with their inner lives working
all right and I'm they're trying to
figure out how these things are landing
it I'm they're trying to figure out what
I'm supposed to be doing and and all
those sort of things the writing
supports the moment the actors with your
support the moment the director gives
you the green light to go there okay and
you know again we did that a number of
times and we did it at a different
number of levels and some levels felt
better sub levels didn't some levels
felt truer but in the end I'm letting
minke make that decision about what's
it's for her overall thing for how the
overall hour of television goes yeah I I
let her know what I thought felt good
right and she also would would be like I
think that's a good one too let's stay
in there let's do it again and let's
stay in that thing that's kind of how
actors work I think it the answer is
good writing a good scene partners
really so no yeah honestly my wife my
wife saw the premiere hey you think it's
better though so when we got married yes
there you go see your that talent you
could pull it from anywhere I like it
no but uh the thing is now Hamlin's a
character a lot people debate you know I
feel like in season one he was more
deemed more as a clear villain but as
seasons have gone on I've learned to
like him more and it's for me especially
this season I've really actually
sympathized with him a lot and
understand where he's coming from and
I'm starting to think he actually is
generally a pretty good guy
now asking the actor himself do you find
yourself sympathizing with him is he
grey to you is he more black and white
where do you see him on that he was
always right but he was always trying to
do the right thing and he can't believe
that his good nature and the sense of
morals and his sense of manners have
been just [ __ ] shoved up his ass
right it means right Kim believes Kim
believes me I mean that's like my
daughter who had been grooming I raised
her - well she [ __ ] eats me yeah give
me a goddamn best I have to cover for
Chuck's awfulness and then I have to
debase myself sort of Jimmy and I all
those things and that's fine is my
biggest rapport is I have to take my own
money to pay off Chuck Jack one of the
pillars of my own company outlet beneath
me the rest of it just laughs the thing
is to kill himself he was the guilt
leaving me with having to go back to
Jimmy to take Jimmy off the hook
emotionally to me what I just wanna ask
you this what the [ __ ] is Howard Hamlin
done to deserve all yeah I want to know
I feel like Howard Hamlin just came to
this interview I love it already yeah
yeah there you go there's a case for
anyone who wants to argue that he's a
bad guy there you go
now do you have any pregame rituals
morning of like a day of filming is
anything you do before you go on set
yeah we get to shoot in New Mexico which
is really beautiful and we love to hike
we love to hike up Cindy about ten rocks
and up antennas mountains and valleys
and stuff like that which is really
great we all try and work out you know
we're not we're not 22 year old staying
out so little the crack of dawn you know
we like to wake up with like the work of
work just as happy so terms of rituals
I'm you know I have to watch my coffee
because I love my coffee I'm a green
juice I'm a California
right so I can reduce first thing in the
morning all right that this is much
coffee discovered your body do you guys
rehearse these scenes or do you guys
just go straight into shooting McKee
ready follow me
we start carving out time on set and
then after work to go over it to starts
coming up with ideas to start talking
about it you know at this point also we
have a pretty good front handle a lot of
characters odds that we can't on it on
each other and we can help each other we
get this sort of work stop it that's not
always the case in in television or in a
work situation but these guys and gals
are real wide open about that you know
anytime we have guest stars we call them
as soon as they get into town to be like
hey can we come over the hotel you might
get to rehearse because we want to have
our lives now yes I'm going to be ready
we want to be ready to play when it's
time to play we don't over Hurst in
front of the cameras we wouldn't work I
mean right no totally so do you think it
sounds like this cast is really tight
and for me seeing on all the social
medias I don't think I've ever seen a
cast this tight in real life does that
do you think that adds to the magic of
the show like is that important I think
so I mean you want to be able to you
want to like the people you go to work
with right and we do and you know we all
have our lives that but you know what
we're also that you know what I think is
a reference of scandal on ABC they had a
no [ __ ] policy I believe I shaved
down from Kerry Washington or maybe keep
down from sod that
well I remember hearing about that and
basically that meant that it doesn't
matter what order you are in college we
are all on this together we are all
making this show from the ground up we
all take pride that success and and if
it's not working out we all take
responsibility for that as well and I
got I got to work on scandal in season
three
yes playing a lawyer took pictures of
his crotch and the Senators girlfriend
but I didn't kill my girlfriend my wife
killed my girlfriend so there you go
then and I found it to be exactly that I
found everybody on that so to be in a
very grateful way of working and it
really permeated throughout the whole
and I and I think we have that on on
Saul not you know oh I hit my knees my
lucky stars oh my gosh but there is that
sense of like we're working with really
great people we understand it it's a
really nice moment in time that the show
was received so well critically and by
the stands well it could not have been
it could have cut the other way we could
have been a footnote right instead we
get to have a whole entire life and be
part of something that's gonna link up
and be you know it look it can be a bit
television history a prequel that
actually links up to its predecessor and
stands alone on and I I mean who doesn't
to be a part of that so we like to get
along and we really like to enjoy it as
it's going on because because we also
all know that spotlight just keeps
movement babies and there's no way to
keep up with it so wow it sounds ominous
I think we're all gonna take advantage
of it and enjoy it
that is amazing now was it tough saying
goodbye to legendary actor Michael
McKean having him died last season what
was it like working so closely with him
well I loved him I never met him before
and it was intimidating and wonderful
it's thrilling it you know he was a
mentor to me whether he knew it or not
by the way he behaved the way he acted
his ability to plug into difficult
scenes and make them real and such an
intelligent man to an intelligent actor
you know and I was like oh there's a
direct correlation between all the books
that Michael read and how smart he is is
to how good he is and so I thought maybe
I should get off Facebook a little bit
get into a library a little bit more so
but working alongside of him I always
felt like oh the scene will be fine
because Michael McKean minute and
Michael will take care of it and in a
weird confluence of events it never ever
happens
my final fans with Michael where the
exact final scenes in the exact order of
those last episodes so my final work
with him was in the conference room
giving him the check setting him out the
door and why the door kick him on the
ass and the way out and that was even
though I knew that in my head I knew it
in my head I was like okay you know then
and then they even saw the episodes that
Michael oh that's tragic and awful and
only at the scenes like that's tragic
and awful it really did not hit me until
the first day of work season four and
were there
and it picks up right where season 3
ends and so there's that uh you know Bob
rail and beam right and no Michael
right and that's when it hit me that Oh
my bed toy is not here my pillar do I
who I relied on is not around and and it
was it was sad yeah so which was great
because it played right into what we
were you know personally I'm sorry he's
not around but the good news is
necessarily been that other back Peter
you know the Showtime shift the last of
all right great that is amazing news it
is amazing there's a I think you really
like the scenes which we see awesome I
cannot wait for that now a question
that's been on my mind and it's very
random but I'm gonna ask you it Hamlin
is always the best-dressed in the show
it's always wearing a top-of-the-line
suit where do these suits go after
filming like do you get to keep any of
them were they like what happens to this
suits are never gonna be my baby there
are really great sheets you know a shout
out to DeStefano tailors here in Los
Angeles downtown they have their Italian
tailors that the best judgment I know in
LA they take care of me they make my
suits they send them to their brothers
and relatives in Genoa Italy I've got
these beautiful suits that Jennifer
Brian our wardrobe designer has made and
90% of my acting work is done as soon as
I put that suit on it's like putting on
a suit of armor I always feel like I'm
the best-dressed man when I walk into a
scene
I certainly have the most I'm certainly
wearing the most money in fact the
budget for the show may spend more on
the suits for B than me at this point
now you know you've done a lot of acting
work and theater on TV I was gonna ask
you with this big roll of better call
Saul being a main role Hamlin is have
you noticed more tension and like your
regular life on the streets like people
noticing who you are as that changed
your life in any way well like I said if
it like you were very kind I've been
passed around for a long time about 25
years I've been a lot of shows people
see me they recognize that they
recognize me that's sort of the side of
their brain way like did I go to school
with you right hey I know you that
sort of things there's a couple of roles
here there that people should have
identified me with but the changes now
when people stop me it's more often
because like hey love the show or hey I
hate your character or hey get off Kim's
back that sort of thing that's fun look
what somebody comes up to you in an
airport this is hey give him a break
just like the show is working I love it
now have you ever thought about going
into writing or directing you know the
answer is no I think I could direct I
would like to direct at some point
that's not you know I'd have to learn
more of the mechanics but I've been
around long enough but I think I have a
feel for it but I would still have to
like learn and whatnot I don't think
ever get a big leap writing you know I
know writers and I spend a lot of time
alone writing stuff rewriting stuff
rewriting it again throwing out what you
thought was good having other people
read it once ago I don't like that and
as much as it's a rejection business as
an actor I don't think I could take it
as a writer because yeah I I just don't
I don't think I have it in me I think I
can tell a good cocktail story and I
think I can tell stories really well but
I don't look like a quite them right
really well so I kept my hat to those
who do write well and spend the time at
it and I'll stick to my side of it
absolutely
before I let you go I wanted to mention
that you still my audience that you star
in a movie called driver X and people
are calling it a/o bur movie it's
screening across the country now can you
tell us a little bit about this movie
like what we can expect absolutely
personal drivers just got picked up by
IFC Films oh no we're gonna have a
limited release in Nationwide theaters
sometime I think in November and then
you'll be able to get a nod to men and
stuff like that it's just followed the
movie at driver X movie on Twitter it'll
let you know all those sort of things
already following me after Craven on
Twitter I'm sure I'll talk about it as
well
driver X to the middle is a
coming-of-age story it's a it's a guy in
the middle age who has a record store at
exactly the wrong time in history it
goes belly up his wife has to go to work
he's unemployed and so it keeps dividing
uber in Los Angeles to make that meet
and to try and save his marriage and of
course
he's a 40-something little guy driving
late-night Los Angeles and the world is
no longer his both musically sexually
and everything else so it's it's about
finding out who you are in the new world
this eclipse so we've been going through
a bunch of festivals around the tuchas
peeking in great responses and and then
we just have is and so this is gone
ahead and lift it up so we're really
sort of a partner with them and
hopefully everyone can tune in either in
the theaters in November or on demand
but meanwhile you can follow driver X
movie
yes everyone makes sure to see a movie
when it comes out it's only getting
amazing reviews I'm seeing so I cannot
wait to see it myself and of course our
man
Patrick me is starring in it Patrick you
can always catch on better call Saul
Mondays and nights at 9 p.m. on AMC and
make sure you see driver X is there
anything else you wanted to promote
groovy called send it which may not cure
cancer but it's a lot of fun for that
summer on Chris all right awesome I
cannot wait Patrick thank you so much
for coming on the show it's an honor to
speak to you and I hope to talk to you
soon you too thank you